hey there goes one of those petticoat
soldiers now yeah my sister wants to
join the wax what are you thinking that
she's crazy what the devil's the woman
want to be a soldier for just a waste of
time this is a man's war what sort of
jobs can they do what sort of jobs can
we do take a look mr. x-ray technicians
inspectors of Army meet teachers
schooling our soldiers wax our
classification experts assignment
interviewers so this is a man's war is
it wax are at work on every sort of army
vehicle doing every sort of motor
transport job testing walkie-talkies
testing radio tubes those are just a few
of the jobs they do there are 239 more
hey you too armchair generals on the
porch here's something more for you to
think about listen General Eisenhower
said in many jobs wax do the work of two
men the army needs and can use all it
can get and listen to the women of the
United Nations lay to have some ideas on
the subject the English with their calm
courage but stalwart women of heroic
Russians the Canadian and Australian
women the women of China with their
undying fortitude and tens of thousands
of American wax what are their ideas on
the subject listen
we shall give up the legends of our
fighting men
where did these thousands come from
where will the United States Army get
thousands more thousands to backup
manpower for battle abroad who are the
women who will help retain the needed
manpower for the production battle at
home who are the women who will help
fight our country's war Mary Jones Jane
Doe
it's the idle housewife from The Girl
Next Door oh yes it's your war to miss
and Mrs America